we've been obsessed about privacy for as
long as we can remember right it started
with the cookie then it became about
transmitting personal information over
the internet you still find plenty of
people that in 2010 aren't ready to be
on Facebook aren't ready to be on
LinkedIn aren't ready to be on Twitter
those are the kind of people that
probably are still not ready to have
their corporate data living out in the
club before we introduced any kind of
privacy settings uh we definitely had a
lot more feedback from our users um from
the segment and it was a minority
segment that that wanted to have a
greater control over just who gets their
plans from a privacy standpoint we try
and give you as much control as we can
without being overwhelming I think if
you frame Your Service as a by default
public sort of thing um people are going
to get that and they're going to
interact with it as such I'm big on
Facebook and Twitter and blogging and
photo sharing and all that stuff so
share share share there's a lot to be
said for people's understanding that
they sort of live two lives there's the
life stuff that they're going to share
publicly and there's stuff that they're
going to keep private how many four
square friends have you got
9,000 okay and 3,000 I can go on Twitter
130,000 Facebook uh
1,700 and then 11,000 on my public AG it
knows where you've been what you're
doing what you're going to be doing
what's your favorite location your
calendar knows all this so now it can be
intelligent and start giving you
suggestions of how to optimize your time
how to optimize your life so our first
notes customers actually had to put
incentive programs in place for humans
to get compensated for putting stuff
into notes
databases it's kind of the same with
calendars I think that there has been a
shift where people are realizing that
the more open they are and the more
they're sharing and connecting with
people the more value it's bringing to
their lives companies are hungry for
that kind of you know SAS business model
and are willing to accept the risk to
get the benefit of predictable service
always upgrading uh fixed cost and you
know sort of all the other benefits if
the pain is high enough that people will
do anything to solve it and privacy is
the least of their concerns when you
know they're trying to solve a a pain
point